we're joining me now is the director of
strategic communications it's pro-life
organization live action Allison Howard
Center Fontaine and at the national
organizer for the women's march on
Washington Jenna
Arnold ladies really appreciate your
time thank you very much for joining us
Allison if I give this to start with you
it is of course a very emotive subject
that has re-energized the abortion
debate I'm interested to know whether
you think that what we're hearing in the
United States what has happened in
Alabama is moving momentum towards or
against the position that you stand
absolutely and thanks for having me
talking about this look the reality is
life is hard it is hard for women
particularly hard for women and
unplanned pregnancies it's also
extremely hard for a preborn child who
has no legal protections in our country
at all none at all
not until you're born even are you given
a chance in this country and so roe v
wade allowed abortion through all nine
months of pregnancy that's not where the
American people are and we're
discovering that we're ready we're ready
to step up and look out for each other
and the claims of poverty and crime and
all these things we need to band
together and solve those societal ills
but why is it that abortion is the only
issue that cannot be addressed can't be
touched until everything else is solved
we need to fight for the life of preborn
children and their mothers together
compassionately and be nonviolent that
is a violent procedure we encourage
everyone to look into abortion
procedures calm okay so they know just
okay copy that
let's bring in Jenna I mean you know
Allison this is a servile imposition I
mean but this is fundamentally an attack
on roe v wade that 1973 Supreme Court
ruling that legalized abortion correct
but let's be crystal clear this is
attack on women on women's sovereignty
to be able to make decisions on on their
behalf on their family's behalf and this
isn't just about women and this is about
men and Family Planning and the right to
choose in this country it's very
difficult for anybody to stand on the
pro
ticket when there anti-choice and
anti-abortion this country is riddled
with circumstances where children are
being jeopardized constantly 13 million
American kids go to school hungry every
single day it's hard for me to give any
sort of credence to anyone who's
standing on a pro-life ticket if they're
pro-gun if they're Pro death penalty
there's a tremendous amount of people
children toddlers human beings walking
around in this country that need a lot
more support than then embryos at six
weeks Addison okay again
that's a distraction tactic we're here
to talk about abortion I don't know why
all these other issues are on the table
we're not even talking about the topic
hair look my dad was born in terrible
circumstances he made it I'm glad his
mom chose life Reverend Jesse Jackson
himself was even conceived in rape I'm
glad he's here we would never look at
him and say you can't be here because of
the way you were conceived or your
so-called wanted nest your humanity is
yours based off of the fact that you're
part of our human family and we have to
look out for the most vulnerable I want
to work together with other women and
men on this because look we're all meant
to look out for innocent lives and
medical science shows this is not a
pro-life talking point you can take it
up with the Mayo Clinic life begins at
the moment of fertilization it's how you
and I got you and you need to protect
each other Jenna I'm I'm the daughter of
a man whose mother opted out of abortion
yet I have raised my hand to terminate a
pregnancy the bottom line is that both
my grandmother and myself had the choice
to make the best decision for our lives
for our family and for for society in
general the idea that that pro-life is
that anti-choice extremists like
yourself are stripping the conversation
and adding rhetoric around it is totally
hypocritical to the rest of the services
that are not being provided to the
people who who are desperately needing
them in this country today the bottom
line is this is a this is about family
planning this is about the safety and
well-being of women and her either
female or male part
about the children that she has to take
care of about the families that she has
to take care of if you're gonna sit
there and say yes we have to take care
of embryos and I'm happy to have
conversations with the Mayo Clinic and
if you want to have if you want to go
into the scientific details of it by all
means bring it the bottom line is is
that we as a country and individuals
don't have the financial and structural
support to always say yes all the time
Alison I disagree with you there I do
not think that you should have a choice
to kill someone that is innocent if that
includes you I don't think that that
should be something that we say as women
let me finish that we as women say my
bodily autonomy is more important than
your body that little girl in the womb I
went down to the stop the band's rally
with the t-shirt that said women's
rights beginning to move because that's
what I needed to be protected most I
have no legal protections in this
society until I'm born and as a map in
their product don't try to humanize and
I recognize what evolves ionize the
biological development of what happens
in the womb but don't call it a girl
when it's when it's an embryo so ladies
if we talk in to each other
ladies if we talk over each other none
of us is gonna be able to hear what
you're saying
Jenna you know I'd like to get also get
your thoughts on there's a lot of talk
about the balance and the Supreme
Court's five to four in favor of
conservative so where does that leave
your side of the argument what position
does that leave you moving forward
concerned gone well the legislature
legislation the legislative bench across
the country has been been rebuilt
consistently for the past number of
years a bit under the radar so to speak
and with Cavanaugh's confirmation it
leaves those Americans seventy percent
of them I might add who support choice
very concerned about what happens if if
roe v wade gets put on on the docket
again
Allison's interesting that Jenna just
raised the issue of polls you know from
what I've seen the majority of Americans
disagree with the position that's a
Alabama's taken is that fair to say
there's some recent polling that shows a
wide spectrum right there's a wide
pro-life belief whether pro-life begins
at fertilization six weeks heartbeat
what emotion do they show that people
are for or against
Alabama's position so about 80 percent
of Americans would limit abortion after
the first trimester according to a
February 2019 mayor's full so within the
first three months of pregnancy there's
conversation there they would either end
it after that or ban it and I just want
to go back to one thing we're talking
about prenatal development embryology
your gender is already there the moment
of fertilization you have your gender
your DNA your hair color even is decided
that's the medical reality your right as
a woman to have a chance at life should
start at that moment because you are
with time and nutrition gonna turn out
like you and me Jenna and so I want to
welcome you to join this fight we do not
need to pit ourselves against our
innocent children in order to succeed in
life that's a lie it's a complete lie
and we should demand better from society
than people telling us that's our only
way to succeed I can't spin eugenics
response Allison I really appreciate you
bringing up bringing up the point about
how we can demand society to do better
and kamal i'd like to go back to to your
point about the the nature of this
divided subject this wasn't a wedge
issue an issue that that divided the
country like it did until the late 70s
when the republicans decided that they
needed more votes and the best way to do
that was to talk about and to show
photos of children to to republican
women to swing them to the to their line
of the political field to increase votes
again this is a wedge issue that divides
this country in ways that are
embarrassing and allison i couldn't be
more aligned with you that we do have to
find ways to bridge the chasm of
division related to how we can create
more of a thriving and healthy
environment for those people who are
currently walking around allison where
can we find common ground on this debate
well this is a human rights issue and a
right is either right applied to all or
to none and so what we're looking at
with roe is does the
person get the guaranteed right of legal
protection to the 14th amendment it's
what Justice Harry Blackmun said would
make ro collapse is if you could prove
personhood of that child and so these
bills are looking at that is it at 20
weeks when a baby can feel pain is it at
six weeks when a heartbeat is there I
mean think about it guys in our society
if your heart stops if my heart stops
were dead so we're trying to compromise
here as a pro-life community and say
surely we can assert that there's a life
there what a heartbeat is present so
we're willing to compromise here but as
of yet narrower Planned Parenthood now
none of these national organizations
draw a line anywhere on abortion to
protect that child in our society right
now it I'll just end on this right now
in our society as a woman you cannot be
discriminated against for your sex your
race or your disability except in an
abortion
you can absolutely discriminate against
someone just for being a female you can
get an abortion for that because they're
disabled because of their race all
totally legal here and I would add age
discrimination to that as well this is
just a term it's time and nutrition to
the final four from you I mean where can
we find common ground on this debate
come on I'd really appreciate it if some
of the anti-choice extremists would stop
characterizing an embryo with hair and
kicking soccer balls in my womb and show
up to have more conversations about how
we can support and protect life today